all right a quick look also at the
bonfire one thing i like about our smoke
tracker and infrared satellite
as you can see the smoke from the
bonfire drifting back out to sea
strong santa ana winds coming off of the
mountains fueling those flames
low humidity from those winds also
warmer winds too
that allowed that fire to spread fairly
quickly all right back here at home the
high today
57 degrees puts us just a few digits
below normal which is 59 a nice cool day
today
and 36 our morning start that was cold
but it's about to get even colder
tomorrow morning which we'll show you
in just a sec right now let's get to
some neighborhoods sky canyon 53
centennial hills 49 52 aliante we're
east side
in the low 60's for sunrise mountain 58
whitney ranch and henderson 53
mountains edge also at 53 at this hour
we're in the mid 50's for prep
55 for mesquite laughlin just shy right
now of 60 degrees
at this hour here's our doppler network
dry as a bone
i'm looking at the extended forecast and
it looks like it will remain that way
too
towards the end of the week we'll watch
and see if the forecast changes we'll
get a slight chance of showers that at
least move into the region
right now it looks like we will remain
dry the big story of course are going to
be your overnight
lows here's how it looks tomorrow
morning in your neighborhoods right
32 degrees is the freezing mark the
edges of town
will be at or below the freezing mark
somewhere at a 30
32 for aleonte 32 also for skycam and
centennial hills 31 mountains edge
34 green valley right the freezing mark
for sunrise mountain
cooler also for henderson 30 for prompt
tomorrow 28 mesquite
and 43 tomorrow morning for laughing
here's your extended forecast 34
our official low very cold with light
winds
those calmer winds will allow
temperatures to drop below freezing
throughout many of our neighborhoods
59 for tomorrow sunny and seasonal that
puts us right near average again
and then we'll start to warm up as we
get to the week however your overnight
lows will still stay
on the cold side and then next week
breezy winds return
on monday milder temperatures at least
for the first half
of the week that is your most accurate
weather update denise back over to you